e
.verif 1:43
(bruit d'animaux)
- Grâce aux nouvelles aires
protégées par l'organisme
Conservation de la nature
canada, cette tortue
sera plus à l'abri
de l'activité humaine.
VALÉRIE RENÉ biologiste, coordo,
Conservation nature Canada
- Les terrains qu'on protège
font à peu près deux hectares.
C'est des petites propriétés,
mais qui sont connues
pour leur importance écologique.
Cet endroit-là est utilisé,
entre autres, par des jeunes
tortues qui viennent de naître
pour aller s'abriter,
s'alimenter et hiberner.
- Il ne resterait que 100
tortues molles à épine en âge
de se reproduire au Québec.
- Auparavant on en retrouverait
dans la rivière Richelieu,
dans la Rivière des Outaouais,
à l'Ouest de Montréal aussi.
Même avec des recherches,
depuis quelques décennies,
on n'en retrouve plus du tout
dans ces régions-là
- Le centre de recherche Zoo de
Granby s'emploie à les sauver
depuis 2010 en servant
de pouponnière.
PATRICK PARÉ
biologiste, Zoo de Granby
- Bon an mal an, c'est environ
200 oeufs qu'on recueille,
qu'on amène ici
dans les incubateurs
du laboratoire de recherche.
Il y a environ 170 à 180
individus qui vont naître.
- Wow!
- Super!
- Déjà 1700 bébés
ont été relâchés
dans la rivière au Brochet.
Il devenait urgent
de leur créer un refuge.
- Malheureusement les riverains
ne laissent pas les berges
à l'état naturel.
Beaucoup de riverains
préfèrent avoir des murets
de béton par exemple
ou enlever la végétation.
C'est plus difficile
d'aller se reposer
sur les berges s'il n'y a pas
de berges naturelles.
- Ces zones protégées
ne bénéfient pas qu'aux tortues.
- En protégeant la propriété
qu'on annonce aujourd'hui,
on a trouvé des espèces
de plantes qui sont rares
aussi et menacées.
Donc en protégeant
cette tortue-là,
on vient protéger
toutes sortes d'espèces.
- Conservation de la nature
Canada espère que d'ici quelques
années, les tortues molles
à épines pourront se reproduire
d'elles-mêmes, sans aide
humaine. En attendant,
des efforts devront continuer
à être faits pour les protéger.
Ici Al